As shown in the previous videos, now we have
a really efficient method of doing multiple
pattern matching using the Burrows-Wheeler
transform. But finding exact pattern matches
might not be able to answer our question to
identify variants when compared to the reference
genome. So we need to look for inexact matching
in order to find these variants.
In general, there 2 methods for identification
of variants. One is called the seeding method
and another is the Burrows-Wheeler approach
as described previously.
In the seeding method, assuming we have a
pattern appears in a genome with exactly one
mismatch, if we divide the pattern into two
pieces, we will notice that one side is going
to match the genome exactly and another side
of the partition has the mismatch.
In general, if we have a pattern that occurs
in the genome with d mismatches, then we are
going to be able to divide that pattern into
d + 1, approximately equal pieces and then
we are going to be able to find at least one
of those pieces that matches the genome exactly.
For example, here is a string of 35 “Xs”.
Assume that we have 6 mismatches with the
reference. If you partition this into seven
pieces with equal length, we will have at
least one partition that have an exact match
with the genome. Hence, whenever we have a
d mismatches, if we divide this pattern into
d plus one pieces, we will always have at
least one partition that has exact match with
the genome.
This is the principle of the seeding method.
If we are looking for d mismatches, we can
divide each of the pattern strings into d
+ 1 smaller pieces and these pieces are called
seeds. And then we look for exact matches
of those seeds with our genome. Once we find
those exact matches, it narrows down what
we have to consider. So we can throw out a
lot of patterns and then look for inexact
matches based on those seed matches.
Another way to identify the variants would
be to integrate a direct Burrows-Wheeler approach.
Recall that when we looked at pattern matching
before with Burrows-Wheeler, we search for
“ANA” in “PANAMABANANAS”. We started
with finding the “A” and we walked backwards
to the other column of the Burrows-Wheeler
matrix and we could find three “Ns”. We
had an “A” and then an “N” and we
would immediately eliminate the “M”, the
“P” and the “B” because they didn't
match the “N” that we were looking for.
If we were allowing one mismatch, then we
need to keep these red letters around. We
need to hold on to them because it may be
the case that we can continue extending and
get exact matches everywhere else and then
we would have an inexact match with one mismatch.
What we'll need to do next is to keep track
of the number of mismatches that we've encountered
along the way. Here, we've encountered zero
mismatches when we've matched these “Ns”
because we have two matched symbols. Here,
we've encountered one mismatched set, the
“M”, the “P” and the “B”. Because
we haven't exceeded one mismatch, we'll need
to extend all these strings.
We'll use the first last property and take
all of the pattern here and find where each
of these elements occurs back in the first
column. We know that the “A” is going
to be there next. So we carry the mismatches
down and we have more mismatches here. So
we need to eliminate this.
Next, we need to identify where those mismatches
are located. We will use a suffix array to
identify where the inexact matches occurred.
We find that there is 1 mismatch in position
5 and position 3, while position 1, 7 and
9 give us the exact matches. With the huge
arsenal of power using Burrows−Wheeler,
we're able to easily step forward and deal
with inexact matches now.